comment ça se fait que le chien était
dans cet état on est en semaine de
séminaire c'est-à-dire on prépare son
projet parce que Roca n'est pas
influenceuse mais c'est une artiste rock
elle dit bon on peut pas garder le chien
dans un endroit où les gens fument etc
ou il y a de l'agitation et de la
musique super forte donc on le confie
d'occitane d'occitaire un peu stupide
qui sait pas qui en fait chez nous il y
a des caméras tout comme l'influenceuse
betka qui n'est pas venu au jugement ni
à la confrontation parce que ça avait
pourquoi et en fait nous on arrive la
police c'est quand on voit qu'on dit bah
on peut pas vous donner les vidéos parce
que c'est Verisure qui gèrent donc on
est obligé de demander à Verisure de
vous envoyer mais nous on en garde à vue
Verisure on voit tout nous on se dit bah
c'est sûr qu'on va sortir parce que on
savait que c'était le dogiteur qui
faisait les sévices mais là vous êtes en
train de dire en fait qu'il y a un
dogiteur donc une personne qui est payé
pour garder les chiens et bien s'en
occuper
non pas peur enfin je sais pas par
plaisir ou pas parce qu'en gros
je vous explique je suis convoqué à la
police il me dit c'est qui ce mec j'ai
eu John le numéro l'adresse le truc
d'entreprise ils nous disent on va le
convoquer le mec il dit non je viens pas
j'ai rien fait